اذا اكيد يا جماعه خبر انضمام رونالدو
وانتقاله للعاصمه السعوديه الرياض مفعوله
ساري وما بيخلص فالاعب فريق النصر الاول
لكره القدم راح يوصل اليوم عند الساعه
11:00 مساءا للرياض العاصمه السعوديه وذلك
بطياره خاصه راحت كلهم من مدريد برفقه
عائلته ومجموعه من المستشاريه الاعلاميين
والقانونيين وسط طبعا تسديدات امنيه كبيره
خلونا نشوف سواء اخر فيديو من رونالدو وهو
بالطياره
سيصوم
كثير كبير ومفاجات اكبر راح تكون بانتظار
رونالدو بالرياض والاهم انه نادي النصر
السعودي حدد مكان وزمان الاحتفال بانضمام
الاسطوره بكره الثلاثاء السابعه مساءا
النصر في ملعب مرسول بارك وقتها راح تكون
جماهير النصر بانتظار الحدث المنتظر
لاستقبال لاعب النصر كريستيانو رونالدو
مصادر لصحيفه الرياضيه السعوديه قالت كمان
انه رونالدو راح يخضع بكره لكشف طبي قبل
طلب بطاقته دوليه اللي بتعطيه حق المشاركه
مع النصر في المباريات الجايه اشارت
المصادر هي نفسها انه كريستيانو راح يكون
متواجد باحد الفنادق الشهيره داخل الرياض
حتى يتم تجهيز مقر سكن الدائم